amazing super cute the most adorable
he's not like
asian baby cute but he's like right
below that and
they're the cutest i think they're cuter
than bunnies and puppies combined
i personally i would throw away 20 white
babies to have an asian baby
but a girl that was so dumb
one time she was literally the dumbest
chick she was afraid to eat pizza alone
she was afraid she joked and no one
would be there yeah
that's not why that's not what made her
dumb she literally asked me what time
she goes
she's going to be a flight attendant she
goes does the
concord is that going to be the sound of
the speed of light and i was like
i think you're thinking of the
millennium falcons
when they when they fly can they not
hear anything i was like yeah yeah
that's right
reported a plane where they all have
chalkboards around their neck they're
like are you a dog
she was an idiot what's up kristin
let's talk about rain real quick man
over here cedar rapids
here man you got a little over inch
that's nothing
look at spencer spencer man y'all are
wet
man it's so easy what is this deck
decora
decora decora they have no rain or that
you just felt lazy you didn't put like
putting in the
total
[Music]
thunderstorms there's
thunderstorms
you guys ready stay home don't go out
it's raining
it's just me and you i want to go to my
safe place
i love you guys we love you see you
later
let's talk about before you guys the
website for the travel channel calls you
professional fun seeker
their website sucks
i love travel channel but they're
horrible
they're so bad they're the greatest
people but man they're horrible
all right before we started i was not a
very good host because i
was talking about how empty a life i
lead your
your sadness was hilarious you told me
about your empty house that's true and
how you sit in your sadness and i
asked you what do you consume like
what's your vice do you drink at night
are you eating cookies and you're like
i'm just i'm consumed by my own sadness
that's hilarious well good i'm glad i
could bring you up with my doubt oh
like you telling me how sad you are has
been the best part of my week
i go to your mom's house podcast.com
there's hundreds of episodes me and my
wife's very juvenile
lots of farts but you know it's a good
time yeah that's one thing that makes me
happy
you like forks i do like that hold on
i feel better i got nothing just knowing
that something was coming
it's good just you're the best i love
you so somebody told me if a bear ever
attacks you all you have to do is pinch
his nipples is this true
or did you not know that do you know
first of all okay never mind you know
what i don't know
this is the most brilliant thing in the
world sorry for you you have the softest
skin
thank you that's that's right okay so
that right there four four four zero
zero zero eight
right here we're ready for
thank you for coming by i can't believe
this is our first time meeting i
couldn't imagine our next time
where i was listening to mark my parents
are getting old too yeah and my dad just
started eating marijuana
because he's got a bad hip uh-huh and
you can tell because he starts saying
dude all the time
he's like dude have you listened to pink
floyd dude and you're like oh it's like
getting high with a ninth grader
yeah so you can see him on the travel
channel
i think my shows are sold out i don't
even know why i'm here
i don't even need to be here
you can buy the bear if i'm doing this
it's on it's on air
and they're like really i go i'm going
to the project that's where i do my [ __ ]
i'll do it
[Applause]
i think you're the only one i got well
i'll go
[Applause]
oh you don't have one under your seat no
no no no no so what is it how do i just
pour it in and just drink it
you can have a sip with me why not just
slide it up a bit so it doesn't
pour out if a friend told me how to do
it
i want to go to a barbecue with you all
right this is my first chewy this is my
only chewy
i mean you might acquire a taste and i
got to do the whole beer right
[Applause]
i'm going to be the enmore theater
tomorrow night in sydney
you're an encouragement from the
audience encouragement
so do you feel better about your body
obviously i never really cared about my
body i never noticed that i was fat
and by the way i'm sure there are people
going no you're still fat buddy like i
hate to break your heart
i know you think you look good you look
horrible i'm changing the channel
but uh south of southern ohio like
cincinnati so much different than
cleveland right you mean like uh yeah
yeah that place that the white people
scare the crap out of me there
yeah that is a sketchy like almost like
uh kentucky like uh i got a buddy jay
uh snyder who's from there and one night
he's like we need to get ourselves some
cocaine
and i went what oh no thanks i'll pass
but yeah and
and looked at my driver's license as we
were having this meeting
and it says i'm 5 11 and he goes bro 5
11.
come on he shook his head then he stood
up next to me and i was like i
am i tower over you come on that's
ridiculous i tower over you you could
eat peanuts off my head
easily how tall are you time 5 11. i did
have a section where i had to decide i
had to
somebody speaks and i have to guess if
it's a black man talking
or me or you tom or black yep really
yeah
yeah go ahead and do it can we hear it
yeah like that
and i had to guess yeah i don't
that wasn't as good let me hear yours
hey dude
what is that what's up what are you
talking about what are you saying guys
he was at the university of miami you
didn't meet him there's a it's a black
guy
you're saying that you want a a black
aggressive aggressive [ __ ] talker in
tennis
yeah that would be the best that's the
ace man
like that ain't no double fault [ __ ] you
like that sir can you please watch your
language please
eat my dick okay i'm going to have to
ask you to get over to the
students your daughters uh 14 and 12.
they both have their periods if that's
what you're asking
oh we can't talk about this no no can i
just make it really clear
that's not what i was asking like my
wife got hers at a
football game wearing white pants oh my
god well it was an alabama football game
so
her dad was like she bleeded school
colors roll tide
so
yeah yeah the whole period thing yeah oh
no i did not see that coming
no when no one no one told you about
that i knew it was gonna happen i just
didn't think i'd be
around my oldest got hers first that's
how it happens right
and so
can we she gets hers thank god i wasn't
there i was on the road i would have
ruined that
yeah i'd be like all right you go to the
river and do laundry for a week you're
dirty
i go do one of these horrible [ __ ]
morning shows
seven o'clock in the morning you know
the the the
moms taking care of their babies are not
like i'm gonna go see this
it's like it's not the right place
publicized
stand up right which is why you did
start doing the character called dj dad
mouth
comedian tom segura aka dj dadmouth
it's all about the after party man i
mean i want to give a shout out to kim
anne
you are amazed and uh uh throat zilla
throat zilla
yeah you've got beautiful young
daughters you can see my eyes
no i can't see your eyes there's just
beer everywhere but
are you going to tell your daughters
about your record do you have like a
plaque at home saying the world's best
party up
my daughters are so stupid we don't have
to worry about them reading anything
they follow after their
how bad bombing feels
to somebody imagine if a girl said you
got weak dick
and then like as she said it another
girl walked by and was like he does what
the [ __ ] this is like a never-ending
line
yeah and then a whole bunch of them were
standing around like you got a chat
like dick dick
so we welcome him in this morning good
morning what's up man shout out to
mercer
shout out to the bristol stool chart i
have number five
that soft blobs with clear cut edges
because i need fiber
there you go tom segura segura aka dj
dab mouth aka duct tape
how did you get that people call me duct
tape man they call me
because i always have it on me you know
like macgyver it fixes everything i'll
duct tape
your mouse shut i'll just anywhere that
you have
a hole on you i'll put duct tape you'll
put duct tape on it i don't take your
ass today
oh skycam oh look at this we'd like to
thank our sponsors at orton homes yes
if you're looking for a house and you
have money
contact orton homes and they'll help you
get it
and if something breaks we'll put duct
tape on it now i got to ask about the
get up here
you were expecting a blizzard in
syracuse obviously no it's just how i
roll man i wrote like this in july
i don't care if it's humid i don't care
if it's 105
i wear fur because there's an old saying
happy hoes eat sad hoes don't and i try
to stay happy
welcome ohio native comedian tom segura
folks so okay before i get into this
shout out to everybody all over the
world doing their thing and stuff like
that
shout out to dainiaks xvlb
you know what i'm saying got it
what's it like at home it's a it's not a
lot of laughs man
a lot of smells a lot of smells
there's a smelly house we have a baby a
lot of kids
babies no it's one kid but sometimes
that's all you need
that's all you need that's all it takes
yeah i mean look there's a lot of action
in the home too you know
like i got i got kids that she doesn't
know about
so sometimes when she's out of the house
i'll bring other kids over
hour long special is right now on
netflix next it's presented by netflix
tell us a little bit about the special i
watched it last night and i was telling
you a story off air
you started off it's hilarious and then
you go into some stories where
my girlfriend's outside of the room and
she goes huh he said what
what did he say yeah well it's dirt it's
dirty
but but it's hilarious yeah i mean your
girlfriend she'll find out i've done
everything there is to do
how in the world have you ever had a
bucket list i've done it all
jumped out of a plane with rachel ray
fought a bear i was the first person to
jump off the stratosphere
jumped off the world's tallest stadium
in africa you name it travel channel
yeah fighting a bear was the dumbest
thing i ever did i would never do that
again you can't
how do you even go into that mentally
how do you prepare yourself uh
oh i want to be famous
[Laughter]
weekend and he is shirtless and all the
shows the funny boner sold out
bert chrysler is here this morning
welcome back shirtless but but i still
have like a muffin top
but i think you feel good about your
body right yeah i'm 44
but you lost 40 pounds i lost 40 pounds
didn't do it healthy but yeah i lost 40
pounds
out of xanax and ambien let's just tap
out at the end of the day oh i'm hungry
no take an ambient go to bed
go to bed wake up skinny
and uh like yeah yeah though let's start
properly i don't know
this is what athletes look like before
steroids
this is america for you right here you
have makeup on on the whole body or
no this is natural this is natural i
i've lost 40 pounds me and my buddy got
a weight loss
i look great so guys
baby seven months old how's that going
it's good
i mean it's very good he's very cute um
he's not like asian cute but he's really
cute for uh
like for a white kid and uh
don't you think they're the best asian
babies biracial babies
to me it's beautiful
i don't look good it's preparing
menopausal women i think they look at me
and they're like
they're like oh that guy wouldn't cheat
on me that looks cool
you're safe yeah yeah yeah yeah that's a
guy he's got a life insurance policy
he'll be dead in 10 years i can live out
my dreams with a young spanish boy
you did crossfit you did say
i don't know we might get in trouble if
i say this i call the guy black
i don't know if you can say that he's
black yeah but i said hey the black
guy's cheating
and they're like you can't say that i
was like why i don't know his name
and then guess his name is wendell i go
oh okay hey wendell
the gay guy says i can't call you the
black guy but you're not doing all your
burpies
i'm sure we can't say that we can't say
that i don't know but i wasn't i'm half
peruvian so
so we've been teaching him spanish
because it's part of his heritage
and i speak spanish and you know there's
also utility in knowing spanish so many
people speak of course yeah and then my
wife's hungarian which is fine
and and she goes i want him to speak
hungarian i'm like why
like so he can be an arms dealer or
something like that
kevin hart i love kevin hart i love him
i've known kevin for a long time
right but kevin's brand now is like work
hard
and and believe in yourself and you can
accomplish whatever you want that's not
real
that's that's that's what this is
irresponsible give me your motto give me
your motivational please
just be at the right place at the right
time just get lucky we were talking
about that today
it's all luck it's all luck like like
trust me if dave chappelle hadn't taken
off for south africa uh-huh
and chris tucker hadn't found jesus
kevin hart may not be working
that's the truth okay he doesn't
acknowledge that in any of it like but
that's the truth
i love travel channel i love scripps
they were nothing but
the that's the reason i have a house
it's the reason we have security it's
the reason my daughter
has a therapist shouldn't have said that
i've definitely been drinking
and you are drinking i'm in therapy too
everybody okay
yeah wheeled out wheeled out of your own
home in a gurney
yeah i have no idea oh it's forever
right what am i counting the days for
you think guys doing life in prison
count the days i don't think so
you do your time i'll do mine
oh no i got out you got help did you
know that
drinking i drink milk out of a cow did
you know that's warm too yeah well it's
coming from their body you think it was
refrigerated
refrigerated from the others
it tastes it's like as hot as urine
yeah it's inside
[Applause]
my favorite rachael ray story ever uh
secret time no one tell this to anyone
um we go to mexico uh we do a segment
down there but it's like sketchy mexico
so we have to have bodyguards
and i uh we're drinking in a room john
her husband's playing music
and our bodyguards are sitting there
just watching us and me and her just
drinking
and she just lights up like in a fun way
and goes hey let's take our body guards
to the beach and make them fight college
and i overdosed on
ghb and like i took ecstasy and i drank
it but it's the date rate drug but i
gave it to myself that's ghb
that's what ghb is ghb is yeah you
didn't really know what you were taking
though right doctors ultimately found
some stuff in your system
yeah i mean i knew what i was taking
because i had taken it before
because it's fun to get high but um
i didn't realize that i shouldn't take a
hundred hits at once
like that kind of thing have you heard
from people uh who
who in some way relate to your story and
they they yeah they're like drugs are
fun you're right
no you host a podcast with your wife
that sounds like a family what's that
about my wife man i apologize i
apologize i apologize i apologize i
apologize to his wife
i'm sorry i'm sorry senores
[Laughter]
you don't have that out of your system
yet bro
[Laughter]
what's up with those tell me
what color are they what color yes black
come on you've been listening you've
been listening
no we've been having a debate all
morning because ariane is wearing the
same shoes about whether they're
navy blue or black look at the mixture
black pants
they're black they're black your socks
are blue yes
we're not but it's not about the shoe's
black
all right well that's it tom zegura has
settled it
i have a podcast too you know what
podcast is yes
why did you take it like that because
some people don't even know
i know some people don't know blue from
black a podcast
is my daughter's got a friend named
alexa and she came over
and she left frazzled because i'm trying
to make a blue apron i'm like alexa
set a timer alexa play sam cook alexa
how do i make a room and this poor kid's
like i don't even know what a rue is
what do you think about your dad well
he's nice but he's really bossy
i didn't drink last night and i went to
the gym and i worked out and then
i saw some guy walking up with bottles
of wine for a wedding i was like can i
get one of those and he was like
sure just one just one bottle
and then my wife said i was talking to
my wife on the phone
and i took a sip in the middle and she
goes are you drinking i was like
no no no no no no i'm breathing so uh
joke and you said uh let's build a wall
around louisiana
right and that made people some people
very unhappy people be like no you you
cross the line
with that joke about building a wall i'm
like do you understand
what time we're living in here like do
you understand the context like
our current administration wants to
build a wall
to keep people out from like quote
[ __ ] countries i'm just saying let's
put a wall
around a [ __ ] state you know